When you request a URL and hit Enter, the browser sends a request to the
server. For example, we can simulate this right
on the command line. Once the browser receives
the response, which is the HTML we see here, it must somehow convert all of
the markup into something that we see on
the screen here. Ever wonder how that happens?
>> You know, now that you mention it, it does feel a little bit like magic.
>> It's not magic. The browser follows a
well-defined set of steps and it all starts
with processing the HTML and building the DOM. The
HTML specification contains a set of rules for how we
should process the received data. For example, the text contained
within the angle brackets has special meaning in HTML and
it's set to be a tag. As a result, whenever
we encounter a tag, the browser emits a token. In
this case, it is the start tag HTML token. Next,
we would get the StartTag, head token, and so on.
This entire process is done by the tokenizer, and while the tokenizer is
doing this work, there's another process that
is consuming these tokens and is converting
them to node objects. For example, we convert the first HTML token
and create the HTML node. Then we consume the next token and create that node.
>> Is there a relationship between the nodes?
>> Yes, notice that the tokenizer emits start and
end tokens, which tells us the relationship between
the nodes. The StartTag head token comes before EndTag
html token, which tells that the head token
is a child of html. Similarly, the meta and
link nodes are children of the head node
and so on. Eventually, once we consume all of
the tokens, we arrive at the document object
model, or simply DOM, which is a tree structure
that captures the content and properties of the
HTML and all the relationships between the nodes.
>> Cool, so we've converted the HTML to the Document Object
Model. It's pretty easy to see why it's called the DOM tree.
>> Yeah, also note that these objects
contain all of their properties. For example, the
image node has a source attribute and this node right here would also have the
same property. The DOM is the full parts presentation of the HTML markup.
>> Okay, so we downloaded all the HTML and
built a DOM. Got it. All right, what's next?
>> Actually, the browser constructs a DOM incrementally and you
can take advantage of this to speed up the rendering
of your pages. In fact, this is something that the
Google search pages do really, really well. Let me show you.